the next talk is on transition so I'm
going to be giving you a survey of sorts
of some sub results which relate relate
phase transitions to we are Gotham for
easing model and I'm going to be talking
mostly about the algorithms for general
graphs there's a huge literature on
looking at algorithms for the using
model on specific lattices and very deep
results those two it tastes like a even
more what do you build me more in the
context of general graphs maybe with
just some degree bounds and seeing what
different ways traditional notions
caters so just just so that we on the
same page what is the easy models it is
one of the first stylized models for
studying phase transitions transitions
in particular that phase transition that
manual show which is of which is of
losing their spontaneous magnetization
when the temperature goes beyond a
certain fixed called the Curie
temperature and this was proposed by
length in the in 1925 bridge and it has
it looks something like this so ever
said it's a very stylized model for a
magnet so a the magnetic self is a model
or some kind of a graph you hear in
these contexts agree and the nodes in
the graph sort of represent some kind of
domain they have two kinds of spins plus
or minus and and there is some parameter
J which sort of represents a inverse and
what the model document is it puts a
probability distribution over all
configurations for all such assignments
of plus and minus spins to the body and
this probability distribution is given
in terms of this kind of a formulism so
there's an energy term which is just you
sum over all the all the edges the
product of the spins so that's like so
each each different edge contributes a
minus one each
agreeing edge converts a plus one to x
the interaction or in temperature
parameter and then the probability is
supposed to be exponential this
exponential and then it's supposed to be
more for magnetization so where is the
magnetization the magnetization would be
some kind of average here so it will be
the average for example of the sum of
the spins
where the average is taken in respect to
this distribution so that's the
classical easing model as as it was
proposed since then it has of course
become quite ubiquitous outside
statistical mechanics as well it appears
and will wide variety of areas for
different reasons for example in choice
theory it's appears as a logit response
or in other words and that's basically
because the rajat responds the same as
something called a global dynamics for
the same reason it's also used for
modeling spirits spare opinions in
networks it's also used in computer
vision or some kind of proxy for cuts
and it's and this is not surprising
because they're special it's the
simplest maybe example of a very large
class of distributions called
probabilistic graphical models and the
crucial property that the model has is
the fall is this one that if I look at
the state of any one node in this
probability distribution then it's
independent of all the other nodes
conditioned on its neighbors and that is
sort of consequence of the form of the
gibbs distribution and but this property
can can be just looked at in more
generality and that's the that's the
whole subject of probabilistic graphical
models and more generally what you want
is that you have some set of random
variables in this case the spins
which sit on the nodes of a graph and
you have the following property that
whenever you have three sets of the
random variables s u NT such that in the
graph you separate as from T in terms of
the graph connectivity then the states
and s are independent of the states and
T condition run you so the easing model
has this property so what I said earlier
was just a special case of and and once
one has a such a graphical model and
there are several questions that our
eyes and our locations and they are sort
of related so two of them that we buy we
will look at or would not look at so
much but we are which are related to
what we will actually be looking at are
approximately sampling from the
distribution so given such a
distribution in some way given some
description of such a distribution you
might want a faster algorithm to sample
if from the distribution similarly you
might want some algorithm to approximate
marginals of the distribution so this
would for example be the question of
approximate in the monetization of some
kind of both of these things could turn
out to be related to this problem of
approximating the partition function
which we will see you next end which is
which is what will concern is for the
rest of the talk and there are of course
other questions that one can ask about
this one of them is to learn the models
so maybe someone just gives us the
realizations of the random variables you
will just get the spins and we want to
learn what the interaction parameter is
or what the grounded line craft so that
we won't be talking about but there's
another kind of question one could ask
about such systems so the rest of the
talk will be focusing on the partition
function in fact also so many but yes
yes in fact yeah so if you allowed money
body interactions and they're
essentially equivalent this
that's the Hamersley Clifford here so so
so for their sort of le work they're
slightly different parameterization
blazing model which is easier to work
with for algorithms so again I am a lot
of grit several general graphs given a
graph again the configurations will be
plus and minus spins and I'd have two
parameters so this they'll be edge
parameter which is some sense a proxy of
inverse temperature and a field
parameter which is or vertex parameter
which would be a some set of proxy for a
field but the precise way I will use
these parameters is the following that
the configurations this plus man spin
assignments will get V is proportional
to this quantity so given any
confliction configuration Sigma there'll
be a factor of lambda raise to the power
the number of plus expense in that
configuration and beta raised to the
number of those edges that are cut in
the sense that they have opposite spins
on their inputs so the red edges in this
so each Sigma I have such a weight
function and then the partition function
is exactly the normalization constant in
front of these weights to make it to
make it a probability distribution and
that's that's just a sum of these
weights and the question we would be
looking at is approximation of this this
this quantity on input graph G when beta
and lambda are fixed
and we'll be looking at two different so
this also wasn't in the talk in the
morning we look at we look at two
different qualitative regimes of a using
model the so called ferromagnetic regime
which corresponds to beta less than one
in this parameterization here you sort
of you the distribution biases itself to
those configurations without agreements
on edges and similarly the beta bigger
than one which is which in this
parameters corresponds to the antics
romantic reason here the distribution
biases itself for those configurations
which try to differ in terms of computer
science ante formatting easing is
something like max that it's supposed to
be 500 mating is something that labeled
min could be supposed to be trivial but
any questions so that this line is log
Peter yeah no I mean with a less than 1
and beta bigger than because so is this
beta is like the e to the power 2 J in
the usual duration it's a beta value
between big bit so here so whenever I'm
talking about real be title already
poverty is the time and it's in the
usual parameters it corresponds to e to
the power 2
okay
so and so this this is pair interactions
but so we had this question right here
so you can also talk about many-body or
higher order interactions so in general
instead of a graph one can have an hyper
graph so where each edge can have more
than two vertices each hyperedge can
have more than two it's use the
configurations still are assignments of
plus and minus pluses and minuses to the
vertices and now no one can have hyper
edge potentials so so these would
basically assign to each but each hyper
edge it'll look at what the vertices
what the spins of the vertices are and
assign a weight and one can also have
vertex pretentious
these correspond where lambdas earlier
and then the partition function is just
the sum over all configurations correct
so I brought over all the all the hyper
edge of the high price pretentious and
taught over all the vertices of the
vertex pretensions and the kind of
approximation that you would want for
the partial function is this kind of
work because fully polynomial time
approximation so given the graph and
some and some accuracy parameter epsilon
you would want to output an
approximation which is within a relative
error epsilon of the actual value and we
would want to do this in runtime it is
polynomial in the size of the graph and
one over the activity per round so one
could ask for a stronger condition of
being polynomial log of the inverse of
the accuracy parameter but that
essentially becomes exact computation
which is just completely authentically
hard for all the problems remember is a
related notion of this which is the
randomized version of this question
which is that your algorithm can now is
allowed to use random bits and now it
has a separate parameter data and it is
it was asked now to have the same
guarantee as before but only with
probability one minus Delta over the
over the toss of its own random points
and then the run time you know has to be
polynomial in the size of y1 over that
case apparently just as before but I
mean they logarithm of it so this is a
related notion that sort of won't be
looking at much but it's cool to compare
it against
so so there's a so I said earlier that
there's a there's a tight connection
between the problem proximity in the
partition function the other questions
about graphical models like sampling and
computing modulus that I talked about so
here is just a dictionary that holds in
many cases including the using model and
graphs which is that that portion
function of response it gives me here
and approximating the partition function
corresponds to approximately sampling
from you in the sense that if one has
the efficient algorithm for one then one
has an efficient algorithm for the other
as well so this holds for a large class
of problems called so-called self
reducible problems the easing model is
not none of that but it's known that it
works for this as well so and this
dictionaries has been used for many of
these classical algorithms Secretariat
that do approximate that partition
function and what they go what they do
is use the dictionary in this direction
so they they try to they try to
approximately sample the gifts of XI
mission and use this correspondence to
use that to approximate the partition
for sampling algorithms to give
randomized algorithm for approximating
the Pisan function this is not again
mostly we talked about me I won't be
talking so this is one another one of
those what we will be talking about is
the other method is it so looking at the
structure of MU and trying to exploit DK
of correlations in you to compute a
partial function so this I will give an
example
we can crack a little innovate next week
so any questions so far
so I said I don't give an example of one
can do something with the kind of
corrosion decay so here is the example
of the antiferromagnet evening model so
so what one can do for the 95 minis new
model is that so let's fix the degree of
the graphs that they're going to be
looking at so arbitrary graphs of just
fixed degree D and then one can plot in
this so again I'm plotting in this plane
of beaten and lambda but for convenience
I'm plotting log lambda and 1 over theta
so far will be raised between 0 and 1
you can plot a line and let's say where
this line comes from and everywhere
above this line in this white region
when beta and lambda lie in this white
region and this line is just a function
of D there is a deterministic polynomial
there FB test for approximating the
partition function the anti-fairy gives
me model so say where this line comes
from and in fact this is tight in the
sense that if you're in the red region
just below the line then the problem is
np-hard so this is also one of the
results in the paper of slides Sun that
was cited earlier in the morning that as
soon as you are in this region there's a
line here and it determines the comp
complexity erotic phase transition in a
sense that on this side you have fully
parameter my approximation schemes on
the other side even if you had a
randomized approximation scheme you
would be able to solve NP hard problems
in randomized Palomita
so where does this this line come from
it comes from correlation decay ended in
the clips mayor and in particular in
from the coalition DK and that gives me
it on the on the tree of the same same
entity so if one looks an article to be
anti Carmody so if one looks at article
magnetic easing model on three of some
fixed
iit-d then it has a following show the
following phenomena which is which is as
follows
so I look at the route but I look at to
conditional probability distributions at
the route one of them is obtained by
fixing everything at the level at the L
at a distance L from the root two plus
this just condition on those words these
two B plus and then look at the
conditional probability at the root so
that's the first one and the second one
is correspondingly obtained by just
setting everything here to - and now I
can look at what the difference between
these two probabilities is as a function
of L as the distance at which I am
fixing word C's goes to infinity so it
turns out that in terms of beta and D
one can draw this line so that was
precedes precisely that line such that
if you're above the line above this red
line so that is log lambda is bigger
than then these the differences decay
exponentially in the length so as L goes
to infinity that is the difference
between the two probabilities goes to
zero exponentially fast in it and as
soon as you're on the other side of the
line in the red region then the the
difference does not decay at all
it remains bounded away from zero and
and this this property is is what is
used so I won't go into the details
where this property is precisely what is
used in coming up with the algorithm
here and and similarly this property of
things not decaying is precisely what
drives the proof of hardness so that so
it is this this phase transition that
it's not it does not only determine the
complexity equation and also it also
underlies what goes into the two sides
of establishing the pistil
so this is this is one so this is one
example where a phase transition notions
aren't what the amazing model completely
captures the complexity of force and
I've got a problem
so this this is for the
antiferromagnetic using model what at
what about the ferromagnetic easing
model so in this so the same picture
that I showed you for the anti-family
easing model that you have this tree and
you can draw this curve and that it does
is that you find out these critical
lambda that all that works out also for
the parameter is model except that in
this case this line does not determine
any complexity theoretic transition so
there is no you can so one cannot prove
this this fact it won't prove such a
thing that above the line that is you
have algorithms and below the line the
form is hard because in fact if I never
got them everywhere so this is here that
for any any temperature parameter as
long as it's ferromagnetic and any field
parameter there is analyzed so a
randomized Markov chain Monte Carlo
based algorithm which will approximate
the partial function of a parameter
using on any graph it does not even
require the graph D Balaji so somehow
although the correlation DK phenomenon
still there on the tree and this
phenomenon sort of captured a complex
picture a transition in the
anti-feminism model it does not do so
for the ferromagnetic so but let us see
what the curve what position do you can
do in the faroe man okay so it's known
that the ferromagnetic in the
ferromagnetic case you can get a
deterministic algorithm on degree D
crops under this condition and this
condition precisely is so if we just go
back to this curve so so if you so that
so everything so if if 1 over beta is so
in the Parramatta case beta
it's beyond this parameter D minus 2
over D then you don't read line just
terminates there so every field at this
point is sort of in the good region so
what is known for the formatic is that
in that situation when all the fields
are good when even zero field is fine
one can get an F PETA's for approximate
in a partial function but
devious collation D can we know that
coalition decay does not hold beyond
this so it cannot be pushed beyond that
so somehow this presence of the Space
Foundation is an obstacle to using this
method so it's an obstacle using the
method of decay operations to get
algorithm but as I showed you there is a
another algorithm that sort of just
completely ignores this barrier and gif
gif gives you a algorithms so the
question that one would want to ask is
is there a deterministic algorithm for
approximating the easing farinelli
giving partial function that that
matches with Markov chain Monte Carlo
methods that can sort of also somehow
ignore this space function and then and
in this talk we will try to give a try
to audit address this question for
bounded D free cups any questions
so and yes on zero the problem is going
this is where they're coming so it turns
out that one can get such an algorithm
and one gets them using using the
properties of the complex zeros of the
of the pyramid leading partition
function so what one can show is that is
that as long as as long as the graphic
pointed degree and the field is bounded
away from one so this so the field
parameter lambda is bounded away from
one so in the usual parameterization
this means that the you don't have zero
field you have some finite either
positive or negative u then one can
across deterministically a block
approximate affirmative easing partition
function and in fact not just in the
case of graphs but also in the case of
hyper graphs and the hyper graphs case
case is also interesting because this
Markov chain algorithm I told you about
sort of has in its proof some combat
Orioles considerations which depends
very crucially upon the ground being a
graph cannot easily handle hyper graph
so we don't know even a Markov chain
Monte Carlo algorithm s sup now to
approximate the hyper graph parties
remedy reading partition function but
this method based on does keep that and
yes so as it will show more it is going
to be based on the on the bar walk but
but will not be any philosophy that has
been discussed several times and already
and
and and and and also on generating some
results of Peters Patel and Rex but as
an aside ever also want to say is that's
like ish so this is these results and
there's no such means they're going to
be Liang theorems or something there's
if one can prove slightly sharper
versions of them then one also get so
this is for Alberta but one can also get
harnessed with a lot of them so she says
like something more about them yeah yeah
yes yes so so yes we can prove in fact
that that the usual coalition is so in
some sense that so there's the coalition
DK algorithm for 95 my degrees in the
model depend upon this technical
condition that something called big
special mixing implies strong special
mixing this is not true for the
paramedic using model in general so so
that is what this is so you can prove
that we expression mixing for the
aromatic easing model this field does
not imply strong fishness and hence the
usual techniques for using coalition be
careful coming up with herbs will not
work
so yeah so what's the thing that there
we are okay so this so this
approximation algorithm going to go in
the following fashion so we want so
remember that a goal is to get a 1 plus
minus epsilon factor approximation to
the partition function that is like
asking for a plus minus epsilon additive
approximation to the log of the
partition function and how does one get
that so in hindsight it's a very may be
obvious a simple idea but underlies a
lot of nice theory that you just Taylor
expand the log around zero so we won't
just this look at the expansion we know
that if we could somehow evaluate it up
to some key terms and the error decays
like X so we want to evaluate it at X an
error depends upon ratio the kata k plus
1 a power of the ratio between the point
where I want to evaluate and the radius
of convergence and and when is such a
thing valid whether it's valid in the
law with the Taylor expansion itself is
perfect and when is the Taylor expansion
valid where it's valid if log that is
analytic and that is that can be said in
several ways so so so so this whole
thing is valid if log there is an
eidetic in the disk of radius R atom non
zero that is the same thing as that X
being nonzero in that disk and sometimes
also written as said being stable with
respect to the disk same thing so so so
then so somehow if we have such a result
that the Parchin for here does not
vanish in some radius then what doesn't
so we have this tea iced and this is
where the so the CI are closely related
to the lowest rate coefficients of this
it's not surprising in the first equal
fields of the Taylor expansion laws that
relate to the first coefficient soldier
marching function itself and and in some
sense they're they sort of correspond to
K point correlations in the model and
based on this and results on zeros as an
embolic show that you can get
approximation algorithms for several
accounting problems so in particular so
here are some results on zeros from
which one can you tell Gotham's so-so
for independent sets we already saw
Shearer at Scotland circuit which showed
that for graphs of degree D there are no
zeros in a radius of about one over e
times D and some from easing model which
Sears in more detail later there's a
beanie on kiram which says that when the
when you're in the paramagnetic regime
there are no zeros in the open unit disk
and in fact all the zeros like on the
edges so so you're just using this and
the fact that we only need to take K to
be about log in to to to get get small
enough error in this expansion
Myron's method shows that you can get
quasi-polynomial time algorithms n to
the login code because just computing
the K point correlations just by proof
force when K is log and takes time about
enter the lottery so so so this so the
next advanced attribute is this very
nice little potato index which give
techniques for making some of these
polynomial time so when the graph is
born in degree they showed that you
don't really need to compute these
correlations in a true force fashion one
can do them in a somewhat more leverage
so that the runtime is only n to the log
data in n to the loggia
so that's going to be the general yeah
but so we need to modify there is a
little bit here but but before that let
me talk about Leon theremin more so any
questions before that I going to that
so yeah so I already mentioned the end
theorem lastly so here is I'm again in
all its glory it's said that when you're
in the easing when you're in the easing
paramedic easing regime so beta is
between 0 & 1 then the zeros of the
partition function all lie on the unit
circle completely determines where they
like in something and and in particular
it's completely the European every
region that cetera does not intersect
the unit circle so in particular to 0 if
we in the open unit disk which is what
kind of thing one would need for bad
enough metrics so before I go into using
this method using the Leanne Taylor -
extensions for proximation algorithms
let me also mention just that in one can
show something when we show this sort of
curious fact about they said the zeros
are actually simple when the graph is
connected and and and interestingly that
this just the fact that a series of
simple immediately implies that certain
problems about computing computing this
Oracle means so things like the
monetization our number B heart if you
want to put them exactly so this is
almost an immediate consequence of just
the fact of the super simple so one can
show that the other simple when the
graph is K so if somehow you can also
use this theorem for some hardness so
select me as mentioned formally the
results so say already said that we can
so we just buy the idea theorem hand up
machine you have to put it on texts and
into the evening modern cups so let's
look at the easing model hypergraphs so
so so the way I define this is that now
we have hyper edges and for each so so
now I can just index the configurations
by set S which is the set of those
pinsetter plus and then the field
parameter behaves exactly the exactly as
before and the edge interaction
parameter so earlier it's it you put a
factor of beta whenever there was a
difference like whenever the edge was
such that had both
and a - and similarly here you put so
you see you put a beta factor for each
hyper edge if into if it it has both a
plus and a minus pin so that's the
partition function and what one can show
that there's an exit after completing
this partition function on hyper graphs
on maximum degree Delta and maximum edge
sighs okay for all edge activities beta
which lie in this region so let's just
look at what this region is so so so
good even along negative beat up here
which is sort of doesn't quite
correspond to what I was only talking
about probably distributions but things
work here so on this side we have 2 to
the K minus 1 minus 1 3 approaches 0 as
K becomes lucky red this lady here is
slightly better so the denominator sort
of is there's a cosine of pi or K minus
1 to the caveman
so it's also both so both these numbers
are always less than 1 in absolute value
so it's always inside and what this is
based on is is an e antenna for Hyper
tops so this result is based on the
following care that so saw the lien upon
graphs now this theorem says that if you
have a hyper graphic where the maximum
hyperedge sign is bounded so it's
exactly K then the roots of the
partition function has defined you lie
on the unit circle provided this this
same condition on beta holds so so as
long as beta is in this range you have
you have the fact the zero slam of the
unit circle and further this is tight in
the sense that if beta lies outside then
I can find a hyper edge in fact just a
single hyper edge of size K where
there's us will not hang the intersect
any fish
and and so this proves the zero of so
yeah so I mentioned in the Barbie not
and particular action before so to use
the whole method for hypergraphs and for
the you model when it should certainly
generalize the potato next method and
but that generalization coupled with
this this extension the DM for Hyper
crafts gives you the algorithm
okay so just to summarize so far so so
one can get using root location and we
will see this more and more I think over
the week using the root location one can
get algorithm for approximate talking
for the evening model on graphs it was
just me and Karen plus will index or
some generalizations and even go get you
can go beyond correlation DK so we saw
it coalition because it stops at a
certain beta this works for all because
not every field is non zero and one can
even generalize this to hyper graphs
where one doesn't even have MCMC air for
themselves yet and all you one needs is
either this new di theorem and
understand violation in fact one can
also do the general to spin systems are
general hyper graph screen system that I
mentioned earlier and that depends upon
another extension of the Liane scramble
facility and Fisher from seventy so so
this this theorem extensions zookeeper
theorem in the special case of the hyper
graph using and can use this
generalization to even handle the
earlier this more general hyper graph
using one-dimensional so so my plan now
is to just give a brief sketch of the
proof of the Leon theorem assign a
original proof and followed by the proof
of this extension so before that gives
there any questions
so let's let's look at the proof of the
Liang turn also so we look at the asana
contraction it doesn't does a note
method it's just mentioned this morning
and then see how it generalizes it's
just sorry - graph is just the product
of spins on three sides you know so yes
so all that changes so nothing changes
on the spins all that changes how I
measure the interactions so for each
hyperedge hyperedge can have more it's a
it's a higher order interaction so a
hyper - can have more so an edge has two
words you the hyper a spin at K vertices
yes so the fan so I get a factor of beta
whenever this edge this hyper edge has
both a plus and a minus spin so it's
like this so I look at those I so my
definition of type edges is not those
edges which contain both a plus and a
minus fit so s is a set of plus spins so
these are by circle cut edges so these
are the edges where which I for which I
will put a beta factor and these edges
are those which intersect both s and V
masses which have both a plus and a
minus and on this on the side side is
exactly the same thing as before so I
just multiply a lambda for all the plus
can you generalize the multivariate case
yes there's already a generation of so
there's already a result of Suzuki and
Fischer which gives the general yang
theorem for that sitting it's not tight
in the sense it's not tight for example
in this setting so so what their result
would give you here is the same thing
without the cosine but it's more general
so it applies pose it to the general
hypergraph easing where you have
arbitrary spin vertices and but it puts
some conditions on them those conditions
are not tight
so the general one fits very truths
differently based on us - it can do that
yeah it's a lot to do that but yeah yes
puts now connected you can count the
number of pluses and minuses so this and
and apply to this it will it will get
this part exactly
so the Suzuki pressure ten apply to this
setting would get this so this time
would be the same but this side would be
missing the cosine yes this one is tight
so I so the hyper edges
in a sense that in the sense that I take
a graph of degree D and even if my beta
and lambda such that this that I can
show that I can find a ground dignity
where there's no DQ of correlations in
the sense that I mean it can take five
number a bipartite graph of dignity has
no decay correlations family of such
graphs to be we persist and addition
decays no hope of working on it in a
sense that it just just doesn't hold so
there is one can show that their
long-range correlations in this crap
however or in this family of graphs but
this method will just work it will give
you a algorithm for approximate in the
partial function is for anti
ferromagnetism model this is what fair
amenities
I mean
so let me just go to hope so Isana spoof
of the idea and then step it in and how
that's how does Jen buy this to our city
so it sounds like as in many cases it's
easier to prove the lianca now if you
look at the multivariate multivariate
generalization so we say the multi near
multi linear polynomial P is has the
nyan property if it has the following
property that it's non zero whenever all
its arguments live on or outside the
unit disc and at least one lie city owns
it yeah if it is non zero whenever
lambda whenever lambda eyes are all on
or outside the unit is and at least one
is strictly orcs it and one can one can
similarly define the multivariate easing
model now so it only difference from
before is that now I haven't I am
allowed to have a different field for
each vertex and for each vertex when it
is have a plus when I multiply its own
field parameter its own vertex activity
per element so earlier the earlier
definition just said all the lambda is
equal to them and and and what Li and
yang proved and we'll see how much this
is that whenever whenever all these so
whenever the edge activity is between
zero and one so whenever is the
pheromonal decreasing then this for long
it has Fillion profit technically
speaking I should also as we actually to
be precise if it's also is G is
connected to have this stronger but yes
resilient operation it does not punish
as long as at least one of the numbers
is outside the unit disk and all of them
are a corner opposite
okay as long as cheese
so let's look at the general outline of
asanas proofs asanas proof it works in
the following way so let's look at this
H books it shows so for the Leone
theorem it shows the theorem for a
single edge first so it will first show
at the Leone theorem holds for the graph
which is just a single edge and then
what it does is to prove this prove this
theorem for some other graph say the
triangle some other country tough with
the triangle it first sort of things up
each vertex of having been partition it
has having been broken up each words as
being broken up sort of into so each
vertex has some degree D and it's sort
of broken into D copies broke into D
copies and and and and and you have the
theorem for each of the edge each of the
single edges and then it starts
contracting vertices and it's sure
so it starts for example with these two
edges and then I show that in the
theorem holds for these two edges it
also holds for the graphs the V graph
that you get by just collapsing this you
had added here I'm holding individually
for these two and it will show that it
will work also for and and then one show
that with these operations you starting
with edges and just just attaching new
edges to the graph and collapsing
vertices in the same way one can prove
the theorem for any any girl and the the
structure of the proof for the hyper
graph would also be similar again we'd
have to prove it for each uniform hyper
edge Sano piece was renée and then show
that it preserve these property Nia
properties preserving the contraction of
vertices
the only difference would be that the
base case in this proving the theorem
for the uniform hyperedge would be
somewhat more complicated than the
assign of you just go through and the
contraction proof would be
similarly some of them so let's just
look at a sauna speak for they usually
enter here is the proof for the single
age so the partition function for a
single H the multi grade partial
function is just this side 1 Z 2 plus
beta times I went was 2 plus 1 so this
is nice and we want to show that this is
V here so this has n BN property so what
is that so suppose that this was 0 if
this is 0 then we can write something
like this so Z 2 is equal to 1 let's say
with all that divisions are well-defined
so Z 2 is equal to 1 plus PT as I'd 1
over be deficit in absolute value but
what is the see now when beta is between
0 & 1 so this is always a more base
transform it takes the unit circle to
the unit seconds no matter what details
as long as the real number
however when BJ's between 0 & 1 it takes
the exterior of the unit circle to the
interior so India is between 0 and once
in the ferromagnetic setting this
transform takes the exterior so if z1
was outside the unit disk it takes that
to the interior and therefore it cannot
be the case when if this if these two
are 0 that both of them are lying
outside the inner disk if that one was
outside the unit disk then because this
transform is taking the exterior to the
interior it's a 2 would have to write on
our inside so so that's that's the
theorem and this also tells you why the
theorem pays for the anti ferromagnetism
model then beat out the bigger than 1
and now the this transform takes
exterior to the exterior and the
interior to the interior so you don't
get this so this edge is already a
counter example and you cannot even
start there and then I Silas then so so
this is one steps to prove it for the
rich how do you prove that so there's
this contraction step so the contraction
step in the Sano setting so what you do
is that you have some graph in which you
want to collapse to word season you have
that the original graph has billion
property and you somehow want to say
that the new graph where the two words
are collapsed also has an en property so
what does corresponds to something like
this that you're the ordinary partition
function if I just look at the variables
here and ABC and
polymers and other variables vertices
then I'm going from the polynomial a
said 1 Z 2 plus BZ 1 + TZ 2 plus G 2 AZ
plus D so why is that so these terms
correspond to those configurations in
means these were to save different spins
but that is not going to be allowed to
come going to collapse so only those
configurations sort of survive where the
two words have the same spin so that's
so only this and this survive and so you
get to this and how does it improve this
so this is quite nice so so if this
column it has an en property that means
that this is not so let's say that or
the other way our values are fixed to
some things outside the unit circle so
if this is not equal to 0 whenever so
because it is niang so this is also not
equal to 0 and both of them are outside
the unit disk but I can take zero an
equal to zero and so we I could either
square plus BZ plus cz Plus D is also
not equal to zero well it is outside the
unit test but this is a quadratic
equation and it it has no roots outside
the units so that means that the product
has to be less than equal to one but
that is precisely the claim that is a
plus D has moved how that so for it to
be zero there has to be there's
something I'm hiding and hiding here
that a has to be nonzero for all this to
work but that can be proved inductive
proof so there's no except for this is
nothing being hidden units it's that
elementary for the for the graph key
what does one do for hypergraph so this
part will remain more or less the same
the complexity sort of comes in handling
a single hyper edge and that uses this
slightly different criterion for the
Gion property that that is essentially a
variation of dividuals characterization
of a slightly different definition of
the Lian property paper in 2010 and this
is the following that now a multi near
multi linear polynomial and you just
which has this property that it's a
material pala means I don't decide and
with all its coefficients nonzero so for
every subset you have a nonzero
coefficient this is the case in the
easing partition function
and it is the matrix it is also the case
on the eating part in function then if I
look at I just isolate one of the
variables and look at the coefficient AG
of that variable then P has Lea property
if and only Ajay has a slightly stronger
property that it's not zero whenever all
the other variables are on or out so you
integrate discs so remember the ly
required that at least one variable has
to be outside the unit disc this is
slightly stronger that is saying that
piece
yeah if and only these coefficients have
a slightly stronger property that they
are nonzero whenever all the variables
it appear in them are on or off said
rainy disk and so this so this sort of
basically what it tells you for a single
hyperedge for example is that it's okay
to just prove the denying property is
true for AJ so or something like that
the end properties with a slightly
stronger was a really a property for the
leading coefficients these coefficients
to get face protects you just need to
prove it for them and then you get the
neon theorem for the whole operation so
now we have to look at what the leading
coefficients of the single hyper is look
like strongly entered so this one can
just do explicitly against so one can
write down what is a J's are one can
write down what this kg is hot and this
property that AJ has to be nonzero
whenever the variables appearing is not
bigger than one turns out to be
equivalent to one over beta being equal
to this quantity and this is now reduces
to depending upon
I think it likes to say that it's a
middle school geometry probably
basically something but the truth is is
to some calculus ultimately some kind of
supplement one that's where the range of
Peter comes from
so you basically assure that this cannot
hold Wendy Peyser
so that's and contraction proof sort of
more or less proceeds along the same
line as the original to some places this
carriage and happen to be used so just
to summarize so one can use zeros oh
Allah needs to get algorithms that
correlation DK the other mean were
coughs were cause of great with a
mystical power bits and at least in one
and in several cases in cases where sir
isn't even where Markov chain Monte
Carlo algorithms are not known so and
more recently sort of a sort of
collision decal says we're struck back
in some cases you can can use coalition
decay like arguments to prove absence of
zero so for example why not so there's
several so it's starting with works of
Peterson checks which is which is so but
one of the things I would want water
dimension is trying to cope with
cinching which which talks about
fissures you just I talked so far about
Leah zero zeros in the field parameter
one can also talk about zeros in the
beat upper and much less is known there
and one thing that one can show for
example what this using sort of
collision reconnect arguments is that in
the collision decay regime so in the
neighborhood equation decay regime the
partition function does not punish there
no Fisher zeros in a neighborhood of the
Fisher of the coalition decayed so so
one thing that I would just like to
conclude with is that so I mentioned
that there isn't a domestic helper of
the coalition decant zero the problem is
but they have this one disadvantage when
compared to Markov chain Monte Carlo
kodos their dependence upon how far you
have to criticality is very bad so
sometimes the Markov chain recording
will also have some dependence upon how
far it is from a phase transition
boundary but the dependence would be
something mild like the running
the polynomial in n times a factor that
goes to infinity as you approach the
transition function for these two
algorithms this distance to the the
critical value shows up in the numeric
in the degree of the polynomial so the
degree of the polynomial goes up to
infinity as you approach the transition
boundary so that that one doesn't know
how to handle and so that's what I would
like to conclude it so if there is it's
just a matter of techniques or if
there's a more fundamental reason that
these deterministic methods cannot
cannot achieve this questions so your
running time also blows up and lambda is
polynomial in first one or it's just it
blows up so it so the run time is so one
over lambda would so 1 minus degree of
the parlament will depend upon 1 over 1
minus 1 over 1 over lambda so if you in
other words you must follow me close to
lambda then you're on time the
exponential phase business do you want
to be at least constant you want to be
passed into
go back to that single operating slide
this is you just write down a JIT for a
hyper graph with J vertices and then you
say what is what does it mean
so one of our media should not be equal
to this when I was it so AJ being equal
to 0 is equivalent of this inequality
holding so what you want to show is that
all whenever's all these are either out
on or outside the unit disk this
function avoids the point 1 over beatin
that you can reduce it to some simple
[Applause]